ça donc c'est la botte avec les quelques
téléphones des airs qui sont qui sont
donc posés ici au début de la journée
qui récupère le soir mais l'enjeu c'est
que ya pas de téléphone dans l'est dans
l'école quand on a démarré le court
clovis on s'est installés donc
volontairement à la faire une petite
ville de 3000 habitants qui compte 50 %
de chômage des jeunes 40% de décrochage
mais 2017 on a commencé avec une
douzaine d'élèves et puis maintenant on
accueille une trentaine sur ce site on
va être très exigeant avec les enfants
il dira des textes d'un niveau le plus
exigeant possible mais le but du cours
d'histoire c'est faire comprendre aux
élèves que l'histoire c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait concret journaux un
monde où les enfants sont bercés de
virtuel se rendre compte que que
l'histoire sipa netflix est quand même
primordial à mon sens on manque
d'exigence vis-à-vis des enfants de ces
territoires en disant que le pauvre il
est issu d'un milieu défavorisé donc on
peut pas en attendre autant
gêne aux élèves de la première année on
a eu beaucoup d'enfants le quai est
connue des violences intrafamiliales de
l'inceste l'alcoolisme à la maison sans
vagues sur le show à partir de la
deuxième année on a vu arriver d'autres
profils de famille pas des des enfants
de milieux très très favorisés qui avait
d'énormes lacunes sur le plan scolaire
et qui n'avait pas reçu de l'école tout
ce qui leur aurait permis de démarrer
correctement dans la vie
non non non c'est une école on n'était
pas gentil avec monde alan gross urnes
c'était un homme la base de tout
un peu
y avait des
avec moi
un gros complexe d'infériorité chez
beaucoup des gamins de ces territoires
beaucoup d'enfants qui se sentent pas
représentés quand il allume la télé les
réseaux sociaux les clips tous à tous
les modèles culturels qui voit il ya des
métropoles est vraiment ils ont
l'impression de ne pas exister et il
n'existe pas à médiatiquement
culturellement et donc l'enjeu pour nous
c'est de leur montrer qu'ils ont une
place dans cette société qui sont
importants qui sont les héritiers d'un
patrimoine magnifique et qui peuvent en
être fiers énormément d'enfants qui ont
été victimes de harcèlement parce que
justement on est sur un mode et de
l'école kipp à mon avis pas adapté aux
enjeux de journée est typiquement quand
vous avez un prof heures en face de 30
élèves éventuellement un pion pour je
sais pas combien de dizaines d'enfants
dans la cour en fait vous pouvez pas
mécaniquement suivre tous les enfants
pouvaient pas vraiment empêcher les
débordements et donc c'est un peu la loi
de la langue dans le dans le cours quoi
l'enjeu pour nous ça a été vraiment de
créer ce cadre apaisé et ça ça passe par
l'uniforme par la relation entre les
profs élèves la présence des profs dans
la cour des petits jouent avec les
élèves d'extérieur on pourrait croire
une petite et très rigides alors qu'en
fait le cadre est très faible mais
l'implication des
autorités elles passent par la
compétence démontrée par la relation par
la confiance qu'on arrive à tisser avec
les personnes sur lesquelles s'exerce et
donc ça demande du temps ça demande des
espaces aussi d'interaction qu'ils
soient gratuits d'où cette idée d'avoir
des profs à la fois prof éducateurs
parce qu'on va créer du lien et ce lien
là il va servir ensuite le court parce
que le professeur qui vous demandera de
refaire tel exercice et bien vous serez
qui verrait bien parce que vous avez
joué au foot avec la cour et vous savez
que il est bienveillant qui vous connaît
véritablement que notre modèle et
pédagogique qui coûtent ils deux tiers
du coût d'un élève dans l'éducation
nationale mais parce que on n'a pas du
tout la structure de coûts on a très peu
de personnel non-enseignant d'écrans
connectés de des tableaux connectés via
un truc mais on met le paquet sur les
professeurs je parle évidemment qu'ils
disaient allez moi je suis trop fier que
mon fils ils disent puis-je aller aux
toilettes ou puisse sortir de table mais
en fait personne ne voit ça comme une
violence de classe au contraire ils sont
très contents que enfants puissent se
développer un capital qui n'ont pas pu
acquérir le naissance et qu'ils puissent
le faire fructifier dans leur avenir
proche en fait il ya une vraie richesse
il ya une énergie il ya une dignité
beaucoup dans ces territoires des gens
qui en fait veulent s'en sortir veulent
pas faire la manche que leurs enfants
s'en sortent ils sont prêts à faire
beaucoup de sacrifices pour ça et un
mépris de classe qui est perçu de la
part des habitants de ces territoires
qui à mon avis joue beaucoup dans les
fractures territoriales con qu'on
connaît donc voilà tout l'enjeu c'est
d'arriver à servir cette cohésion
territoriale
sans être dans le misérabilisme
on est convaincu que c'est en faisant
vraiment confiance aux excellence qui
résident dans ces territoires qu'on va
permettre à la france périphérique de
trouver son modèle de croissance son
modèle de pérennité son modèle de
prospérité
[Musique]